The culture, traditions and especially the native language...
...of this European country are distinctive.
Welcome to Watchmojo.com, and today...
...we'll be learning more about the cultural attractions of Wales.
Literature has always been an important part in Welsh culture...
...with its literary tradition dating as far back as the sixth century.
The country is extremely proud of its poets.
For instance, the residence of late poet Dylan Thomas, known as the Boat House,...
...has been transformed into a museum that is open to the public.
It is located in the town of Laugharne,...
...which is notable for its Georgian town houses and the Laugharne Castle.
There is no shortage of museums when it comes to Wales.
Tourists are often drawn to St. Fagans National History Museum in South Wales.
Admission is free to this open-air museum,...
...which stands in the grounds of St. Fagans Castle and gardens...
...and documents Welsh history through its buildings and exhibitions.
Another national museum is the Roman Legionary Museum and Amphitheatre.
The museum is located in Caerleon, which lies inside of the Isca Augusta fortress.
The Oriel Ynys Mon museum and arts center provides historical and cultural insight...
...on the Isle of Anglesey through permanent displays,...
...such as the Sir Kyffin Williams collection.
Environmentalists can take a tour of the Center for Alternative Technology in Powys,...
...which teaches sustainable development and eco-friendly living.
The main attractions of the center are its interactive exhibits,...
...including those displaying wind and solar power.
Whether it's beautiful Celtic art, literary figures...
...or even historical context you're interested in,...
...Wales has got a cultural spot just for you.